next we have noon Hagia who's an
associate professor of business
administration and a Marvin Bower fellow
in the general management unit of
Harvard Business School
his research centers on the question of
whether and how managers ought to be
guided not only by considerations of
economic efficiency but also by values
such as freedom and fairness and their
respect for basic rights he has pursued
this question in a variety of contexts
including the employment relationship
and the operation of multinational
enterprises in developing economies
he's also studied he also studies
foundational aspects of this question
examining principles for rational
decision making when choices involve
multiple values that appear incompatible
at harvest at Harvard Business School
professor Xie teaches leadership and
corporate accountability to first year
MBA students into executive education
participants in the program for
leadership development he joined the
faculty from the Wharton School of the
University of Pennsylvania where he was
an associate professor of Legal Studies
and business ethics and served as a
co-director of the Wharton ethics
program
he holds a BA in economics from
Swarthmore College and MPhil in politics
from Oxford University and a PhD in
economics from Harvard University
so dr. Xie we've heard about you know
the beginnings of a framework for
thinking about the ethical health of
organizations
and there's the suggestion that
humanistic management has this
distinctive role to play in that what do
you think what if anything distinguishes
humanistic management from other
accounts of managerial responsibilities
and and how do those accounts relate to
the concepts of humanistic management so
that's a great question bill thanks for
asking it I'm not trying to be able to
access are anybody hear me I have a
little bit of a cold I apologize I'm not
trying actually provide a definitive
account of what is humanistic management
but what I wanted to do was try to see
if we can't bring
the idea of humanistic management into
conversation with existing accounts of
managerial responsibilities as a way to
try to sharpen just what it is that is
distinctive about humanistic management
because on the surface I think it's
actually quite appealing right and so it
really understands and be able to press
forward what it is that makes the
appealing I think it's actually helpful
to try to put it into conversation with
existing accounts so we take the
definition of humanistic management
that's provided here in the materials
for the the conference since humanistic
management protects human dignity while
promoting human well-being in an
economic system in which all
stakeholders are equally respected and
where market mechanisms are applied to
max my societal benefits rather than
individual profits and I think that's a
very appealing ideal but take for
example something like the Milton
Friedman view of managerial
responsibility okay
to maximize say profits shareholder
returns through voluntary transactions
in the context of economic activity
subject to respecting the law right now
on one view as to what justifies that as
the appropriate account of managerial
responsibilities you could see actually
looks quite close to a humanistic
account of Management right the idea is
to respect individual freedom individual
choice and it's the respecting
individual freedom and individual choice
through market exchanges that we then
realize overall social well-being okay
so the question then is what is it about
that description of the Friedman view of
managerial responsibility that doesn't
meet up with the account or ideal of
humanistic
management and so I want to suggest
basically three three ways in which they
might might diverge and I think those
are three dimensions on which to press
the account for humanistic management to
perhaps define itself sharply as an
alternative to to what you might call
standard accounts of managerial
responsibilities so the the first
dimension is the idea of of what you
might call preference okay
and the second one is what I'll call
power and the third one is what I'll
call purpose so we have preference power
and purpose let me say a little bit more
about what I mean by each of those
dimensions and and where we might try to
broaden or enrich the discussion I'm
amused to hear from all of you as to how
you would fill in those three areas with
regard to thinking about what is
humanistic management first with regard
to preference I think on most not just
the the Friedman view right but most
liberal views right preference plays a
very powerful role because it's both by
satisfying individual preference that we
achieve societal well-being right and
similarly it's by respecting individual
preference that we also respect
individual choice so insofar as human
dignity is about trying to achieve
overall social well-being right and also
about respecting individual choice then
the account of dignity has to do more
than say something simply about it being
an account that respects individual
preference right and that I think is a
very important area especially because
the appeal of the liberal account is
that it allows for a wide-ranging set of
views of the good life it allows for
wide-ranging set of views about what it
is that makes people's lives meaningful
and especially in a global economy right
being able to allow for that I think is
very important so the question is is
there a way to account for individual
well-being an individual choice
in a way that simply isn't about
respecting preference that comes to the
idea of humanism but at the same time
allows one to do that in the context of
a global economy where there is a
plurality of values and a plurality of
conceptions of what it is to lead the
good life so that's sort of the first
first dimension I think that we be
interesting to talk a little bit more
about the second one is power
okay the Beast I focus on powers that I
think that actually that's one area
where the classical liberal view in
economics doesn't do a very good job of
accounting for because in the classical
liberal view basically everything is a
matter of exchange right and a short of
any sort of severe form of coercion or
physical restriction right basically
it's a matter of economic exchange and
when I think about the concern of
dignity I my sense is that the concern
with dignity really is about a concern
with the appropriate exercise of
managerial power all right in other
words that a lot of the concern with
dignity is about how is it that managers
are exercising their power visa via
employees for example in the firm and so
they asked is one area where where the
human humanistic approach to management
actually has a lot more to say that can
be quite valuable to add to the standard
kind of classical account of thinking
about management and economics where
everything isn't simply about exchange
but there is a dimension of power that
goes unrecognized that needs to be be
addressed and then the question becomes
is is dignity really simply just about
right the appropriate exercise of power
so say for example power is non
domination right or power as a respect
for fairness or is humanistic management
and dignity require more than simply
just what might be called either the
unfair or dominating use of power which
could be accommodated in a liberal
approach at last miss purpose
and by this I mean the purpose of both
economic activity in general but also
the purpose of the firm now the standard
liberal view I think is very
conveniently melts together the view
that if individuals pursue their own
purpose in the context of the firm where
you can imagine that leads to the
overall satisfaction of social welfare
right and in some of the literature on
humanistic management I read about the
idea of serving the common good as sort
of underlying what it is the purpose of
the firm and business activity should be
and I don't mean to be provocative but I
actually would want to raise sort of one
question which is is pursuit of the
common good actually intention with
respect for human dignity okay because
you can imagine all sorts of pursuits in
the common good which require great
sacrifice on the part of individuals and
so the insofar as human dignity is about
actually respecting individuals I wonder
if appeal to the common good is the
right appeal to sort of look to with
regard to thinking about purpose in the
context of economic activity okay at the
same time I can understand the
resistance on the part of humanistic
management to sort of focusing on simply
the purpose of economic activity is
whatever individuals themselves choose
as the proper ends of the Association or
the proper ends for themselves and so
the question is is there something in
between the idea of the common good and
sort of the simple pursuit of individual
purpose my own thought is that there's
something there and thinking about the
idea of thinking about economic activity
as the creation of meaningful
opportunity for individuals to pursue
their own ends and that's sort of my own
view about how to think about it and and
and I'm happy to talk about that later
but I think trying to understand purpose
is this sort of one last thought and I
getting one way to wrap it up is to put
the question to humanistic management as
follows
is whether the market is in fact a
sphere in which human dignity can be
realized and the right set of
institutions to realize it in other
words is there something about markets
that helps to realize from and I human
dignity right or is a humanistic
management approach basically taking the
market as given and saying look we have
the market okay they may be desirable
for other reasons and the question is to
tame the market in a way to make it
appropriate for human dignity and and so
I think answering that question may be a
way to get at some of the issues with
regard to thinking about a preference
power and also purpose so thanks very
much
you